The mood of the city today is really happy.
It's really vibrant 'cause the sun's shining...
...and everyone's really happy and bouncy which is a lovely surprise for October.
I love the drive across any of the bridges going along the South Bank.
I love driving around through that part of London like around Westminster...
...and around the Houses of Parliament and Westminster Abbey.
I just think it's all so beautiful.
And then you get the water too, which...
...I love being near water.
I think the people in London make me the most proud of the city.
I think what comes out of it is such great music...
...and such great art and such great films and such great fashion.
I think that London's really a sum of its parts.
When I'm ever away from my city I miss roast dinners.
I miss going to the park.
And yeah, I miss the spirit of Londoners when I'm away.